the responsibility for starting the
conflict for growing number of victims
lies totally with the west and with Kiev
regime for whom Ukrainian people are not
their own effectively
this regime is not serving their
national interests they're serving
interests of foreign powers
the
Ukraine is is now like a training ground
for them
I'm not going to talk about the plans of
Western powers to increase military aid
everyone knows about this but one thing
is is uh very clear to everyone the the
greater the range of this systems the
further away we will be forced to move
the threat from our borders
[Applause]
the elites of the West are not hiding
their goals
they are as they say trying to inflict a
strategic
um defeat on Russia what does that mean
to us that means they want to end with
Russia they want to turn a local
conflict into a phase of uh global
conflict
this is how we understand this and this
and we will react in an appropriate way
because in this case we're talking about
existence of our country
they also have to take into account that
it is impossible to defeat Russia on the
battlefield